[Música]
el mes de enero está por terminar y
Estados Unidos ha vivido unas de las
semanas más violentas en cuanto al
número de tiroteos y masacres según el
reporte de la gran violence arcaive en
el país han tenido lugar 39 tiroteos en
los que un total de 69 personas han
perdido la vida según la misma
organización es una sorprendente
explosión de violencia en Estados Unidos
el presidente de ese país Joe biden
volvió a hacer un llamado para que desde
el congreso se tomen medidas legales
para evitar este tipo de casos que tal
parece se están comenzando a normalizar
en la sociedad de Estados Unidos
mi amiga la senadora diamon facetime re
introdujo su prohibición de armas de
asalto en el senado les pido a todos que
las envíen a mi escritorio lo más rápido
que puedan realmente se necesita Con
urgencia
si bien cada vez que sucede una de estas
tragedias se avivan los llamados para el
control de las armas también se
incentiva la compra de más y más armas
para quienes creen que es la mejor forma
de defenderse si en algún momento se ven
en un escenario de un tiroteo otro
factor es la frecuencia los tiroteos
ocurren en diversidad de lugares en
oficinas en escuelas secundarias en
parques en espacios en centros de culto
religioso también en supermercado
restaurantes centros comerciales y cada
vez son más seguidos la sensación es que
en Estados Unidos puede ocurrir en
cualquier lugar en cualquier momento un
tiroteo y como esto pues capta la
atención de la sociedad está atendiendo
entonces a normalizarse
sistema de violencia es uno de los
puntos que vamos a analizar Cómo hacer
frente a este fenómeno tiene la sociedad
de Estados Unidos una particularidad que
está normalizando esta forma de actuar
la solución Es simplemente agarrar un
rifle y disparar abiertamente en donde
quiera que uno esté Qué carencia hay a
nivel psicológico dentro de la sociedad
de Estados Unidos y dado que luchar
contra el lobby de las compañías
fabricantes de armas es muy difícil
entonces cómo enseñarle a los
estadounidenses a hacer un buen uso de
las armas ya que allí pues es
completamente legal adquirirlas qué es
lo que le pasa a los estadounidenses que
tienen que andar armados porque esta
sensación de estar a la defensiva en su
diario vivir ni siquiera en países que
están en guerra se ve este tipo de casos
con tanta frecuencia como está
sucediendo en Estados Unidos pues todas
estas preguntas las vamos a tratar de
responder hoy aquí en el debate de
France 24 para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a ron aledo él es excontratista
de la también es oficial del ejército de
Estados Unidos y oficial de operaciones
e inteligencias del Estado Mayor también
está con nosotros Refugio Rodríguez él
es jefe de equidad de la ong hell en el
estado de California es una institución
que promueve el no uso de las armas en
Estados Unidos vale la pena aclarar que
los argumentos que serán expuestos a lo
largo de este programa no representan a
ninguna de estas organizaciones en las
que colaboran nuestros invitados del día
de hoy la exposición de sus argumentos e
idea es todo a título personal es la
opinión el análisis de ellos para que no
haya malentendidos
nuestros televidentes les recuerdo que
también hacen parte de este debate
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
ya lo saben estamos en Twitter en
Facebook en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba franz24 guión bajo s
@santilogo en la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios es numeral el debate
f-24 todo junto les recuerdo también que
todos los contenidos del programa
también están disponibles en diferentes
plataformas en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
le doy entonces la bienvenida a Run y
gracias por estar con nosotros en el
programa ROM bienvenido y la pregunta de
Punto de partida para comprender lo que
está pasando en Estados Unidos qué es lo
que pasa en la sociedad estadounidense
que son cada vez más habituales este
tipo de tiroteos este tipo de
escenarios en donde una persona dispara
abiertamente sin importar el lugar donde
se encuentre Cuáles son las motivaciones
Hola muy buenas por la invitación Bueno
la la situación es una situación muy
compleja que hay que estudiarlo desde un
punto de vista sociológico no pero hay
muchos tipos de
de crímenes Por decirlo así o delito
utilizando las armas de fuego una cosa
es el crimen como tal de utilizar un
arma de fuego contra otra persona o
personas otro es lo que Nosotros
llamamos más putins o disparar en masa
que son cada incidente donde hay cuatro
personas más envueltas y otra cosa muy
diferente y muy particular son los más
que útil de las escuelas eso es una es
un tema muy particular y muy específico
O sea que hay diferentes niveles
diferentes cosas que se pueden definir
una de las situaciones que más que más
influye con el con el gran número de
personas que mueren o de incidentes de
más que hay te repito son cuatro
personas o más pues son obviamente los
los robos son obviamente la falta de
Salud Mental son obviamente pues
trastornos psicológicos de los
diferentes personas y en algunos casos
también extremismo político y esas son
las situaciones más normales que que
están detrás de las de las estadísticas
de todos los años Bueno muy importante
esa diferenciación que hace usted entre
los tiroteos masivos que la mayoría son
actos premeditados por las personas que
lo cometen pero también hay otro tipo de
hechos violentos como los asesinatos
entre pues diferentes personas las
venganzas personales
los cobros entre las diferentes
pandillas por temas de tráfico de drogas
también los tiroteos que surgen en
diferentes disputas ese es un punto
importante lo vamos a analizar y a
profundizar en unos minutos Run quiero
darle la bienvenida también a Refugio
que está con nosotros Bienvenido al
programa Gracias por estar hoy en el
debate de 24 refugio y la misma pregunta
para el inicio Qué es lo que está
pasando en la sociedad estadounidense
que son cada vez más habituales este
tipo de tiroteos masivos y cuáles son
las motivaciones
mucho gusto este Muchas gracias y un
placer de conocerte este
yo estoy de acuerdo con mucha la
información que que contribuyó lo único
que agregaría es de que debemos de
recordar de que los incidentes donde hay
tiroteos solo solamente representan un
por ciento este de todas las muertes que
ocurren en este país a través de de
armas de fuego también debemos recordar
que que unan dos muertes que existen en
ese país a causa de un arma de fuego son
suicidios Entonces aunque las cifras se
ven horribles para las muertes que
existen en términos de suicidios o o de
tiroteos masivos la gran mayoría de
muertes que existen en términos de armas
de fuego Son son este daño a sí mismo
personas que se suicidan
también importante ese dato Refugio paso
a preguntarle a ron para entender el
contexto de Estados Unidos por qué en
este país
se tienen armas porque los ciudadanos se
ven en la necesidad de tener armas en
sus casas porque la venta libre y porque
esto se normalizó en la sociedad de
Estados Unidos cuando vemos otros países
que tienen la misma calidad de vida o
mejores condiciones que Estados Unidos
en donde no se fomenta este tipo de de
uso de armas porque es normal allí
bueno esa es una de las cosas
particulares que tiene Estados Unidos no
Estados Unidos tiene muchas cosas
particulares que no comparte con digamos
con Europa ni con Canadá ni con y con
otros países occidentales no y es una de
las cosas particulares que tiene es las
armas que se utilizan históricamente Por
decirlo así
desde los vaqueros de que podemos ver en
las películas
desde el activismo político la gente les
quiere armas para proteger sus casas la
gente utiliza armas para la casa aquí la
casa es un deporte nacional que va de
Costa a Costa independientemente del
estado donde viva para competencias de
tiro al blanco o sea que es una cosa
profundamente arraigada en la cultura de
Estados Unidos lo que pasa simplemente
es que está tan arraigada en la cultura
en la política que increíblemente
difícil cambiar una cosa que lleva
décadas y siglos de hecho
dentro de la cultura de Estados Unidos
las divisiones Claro está las personas
de las grandes ciudades más bien del
noreste de Estados Unidos ahí Hay
muchísimas más restricciones pero si te
vas a las ciudades y a los Estados más
de tierra dentro lo que nosotros decimos
el sur las áreas Rurales pues es una
cuestión típicamente cultural
la la tener armas la pesca la casa es
una cosa que está profundamente
arraigada dentro de la cultura y la
política de Estados Unidos Refugio su
opinión porque hay que tener armas en
Estados Unidos
es muy complicado en este país
desafortunadamente es algo que
fueron los principios de este país está
muy arriesgado en la segunda enmienda de
este de la Constitución y hay personas
que realmente Eso es parte de la cultura
yo yo soy descendencia mexicana yo me
crié con armas también este yo lo tengo
armas en mi hogar simplemente por el
trabajo que hago y y por el daño que he
visto que que ha hecho he tenido acceso
armas en mi juventud también este y la
realidad es de que es es algo muy
arraigado No aquí en Estados Unidos El
el acceso Yo pienso que esa es una de
las grandes diferencias de lo que vemos
el derecho a tener acceso y yo pienso
que la dificultad que está teniendo este
país es que estamos viendo de que tal
vez uno necesita de restringir el acceso
a personas
en términos de y ya lo hacemos verdad
personas que son restringidas hacer
ciertas cosas este en diferentes estados
por felonías como estaba diciendo run en
en California tenemos muchas
restricciones y sin embargo Todavía
existe este actos de tiroteos masivos
entonces en eso están a muchos de los
estados este tratando de reconciliar
como este
hacer restricciones en acceso para
personas que realmente no deben de tener
armas y cuáles son las determinaciones y
Y eso es muy difícil porque en este país
la segunda enmienda este es algo que hay
hay ciertas personas en aspecto político
que defienden eso y no importa Este
Cuáles restricciones uno quiera imponer
este se ven como una como una pelea
encontrada segunda enmienda
Refugio continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa viendo entendido
esta facilidad que hay en el acceso en
Estados Unidos para adquirir las armas y
también algunas de las restricciones que
hay dependiendo de los estados porque
cada estado tiene una una legislación
particular o diferente Hay algún aspecto
psicológico en la sociedad en Estados
Unidos que les haga pensar que están en
estado de vulnerabilidad que hay
necesidad de tener un arma en casa para
sentirse más seguros o que simplemente
yo descargo todas mis inconformidades
con la sociedad a través de ir a
dispararle a más gente porque también lo
vemos en algunos de los casos de estos
tiroteos masivos son personas que es que
les hacían bullying en la escuela
entonces fueron a realizar digamos un
acto de venganza Pues bueno a muchos nos
han hecho bullying a lo largo de nuestra
vida pero acá estamos conduciendo un
programa justamente para debatir eso y
no estamos echando bala abiertamente en
las calles
Sí yo pienso que en cierta forma Yo
trabajé por mucho tiempo en en el área
de Salud Mental en el área de Salud
Mental cuando cuando uno se está cuando
estamos hablando del suicidio por
ejemplo es algo impulsivo y la
impulsividad este y vamos a decir yo
quitarme la vida o querer quitarme la
vida con con píldoras o alguna otra
forma es muy diferente Que quitarme la
vida impulsivamente con un arma de fuego
este la probabilidad de sobrevivir a un
balazo al cráneo es solamente diez por
ciento en esos en esos de esos intentos
y las personas que sobreviven no
sobreviven muy bien este la la calidad
de vida que tienen está dañada
significadamente este para mí Yo pienso
que debemos de de de
investigar mucho más estos casos esto es
esto es algo que que está ocurriendo ya
muy frecuentemente y es necesario tratar
de investigar y saber cuáles son los
riesgos que existen como estaba diciendo
usted a muchas personas le hacen bully
Este pero también Tenemos muchos
ejemplos en otros casos donde personas
que van a Guerra y no son afectados y
otras personas que el vuelven muy
afectados entonces hay hay mucho que ver
pero al mismo tiempo yo pienso Por eso
estaba diciendo que
hay etapas en la vida de unas de
personas donde estamos en crisis donde
yo pienso que sería buena idea que este
habláramos seriamente de restringir de
restringir el acceso a armas no nomás
por el bienestar de uno pero por el
bienestar de otros Este Y de nuevo no no
más todavía hablando de tiroteos masivos
estamos hablando en general porque en
cierta forma Si una persona está
deshabilitada este no lo permitemos a
esa persona a manejar este igualmente Yo
pienso que armas de fuegos este por el
peligro que existe este deberemos de
tener esa conversación
Claro porque hay que pensar no solamente
en el individuo en que pueda atacarse a
sí mismo sino que como individuo que
pertenece a una sociedad también eso va
en pro de mejorar las condiciones de la
sociedad Run le doy la palabra a usted
para que también nos dé su opinión sobre
este aspecto psicológico hay algo
particular de la sociedad de Estados
Unidos que los haga pensar que tener un
arma es sinónimo de seguridad Cuál es su
opinión
bueno son dos temas diferentes En mi
opinión una una cuestión es el trauma
psicológico que tienen los adolescentes
que son inmaduros no que
y niños también y adolescentes que son
bullying que son abusados en la escuela
durante años y años y años porque son
muy delgados muy flacos muy débiles
tal vez muy intelectuales no atletas se
burlan de ellos durante años hasta que
un día pues dada su su debilidad
psicológica pues deciden vengarse de los
de los que por años los han torturado y
han humillado y han y se han burlado de
ellos y deciden desgraciadamente hacer
estas cuestiones de de más shootings en
las escuelas esa es una gran tragedia y
una cuestión que tiene que ver con
muchísimo con con la con los daños
psicológicos de estos muchachos eso es
un tema en específico Es sobre las casas
pues ya ya dije hay montones de razones
por la que la gente tiene armas en las
casas aparte de la defensa personal la
casa la competición etcétera es una
cuestión muy pero que muy arraigada
especialmente en el sur de Estados
Unidos en las áreas Rurales de Estados
Unidos etcétera Pero hay otro argumento
también que utiliza la gente para tener
armas en la casa para defensa personal y
es el alto número de de criminales que
tienen armas y el alto número de
personas con con récord criminal o que
han salido de presión que obtienen armas
ilegales en el mercado negro Entonces
muchísima gente que
que personas de Ley y orden que siguen
la ley y el orden dicen puesto que los
criminales a pesar de ser criminales
tienen armas que consiguen en el mercado
negro de forma ilegal obviamente de
forma de contrabando yo para proteger mi
casa para proteger mi familia voy a
tener un arma de forma legal por si
acaso Dios no lo quiere Algún día algún
criminal Trata de entrar a mi casa eso
es uno de en algún momento que más se
utiliza para el el únicamente para el
tema del pensar personal pero entonces
ron a partir de esta de esta de este
motivo que usted nos explica esto
empieza a volverse Entonces como un
círculo vicioso porque
digamos que hay un doble efecto de la
situación la gente siente que este tipo
de hechos de tiroteos masivos Puede
ocurrir en cualquier momento y lo mejor
que puedo hacer es estar preparado para
defenderme Entonces lo mejor que puedo
hacer es comprar un arma es es un
círculo vicioso la gente lo lo hace para
protegerse no pensando justamente en ir
a cometer un acto de manera premeditada
sino en en defensa Cómo romper ese
círculo vicioso
bueno son dos cosas para para que el
público que posiblemente no no está
familiarizado con Estados Unidos me
entiendo son dos cosas más o menos
separadas una cosa es la defensa
personal de la casa
para eso la gente de Estados Unidos no
necesita una licencia en específico en
casi todos los estados son solamente
necesita pasar una pasar una
investigación Federal muy rápida que se
hace por ordenador por computadora el
FBI el departamento de Justicia hace un
un tipo de background muy muy rápido y
dice que y si no tiene ningún récord
criminal o no tienen ningún caso
pendiente ante la justicia te dan el
arma otra Eso es para defensa personal
en la casa ahora bien lo que hacen
muchos estados es que si tú quieres
llevar un arma en la calle para
protegerte de uno de estos premeditados
o
tiroteo masivo que pueda surgir de
manera no premedita entonces si te
necesitas sacar una licencia para tener
el arma en la en la calle lo que
Nosotros llamamos aquí con carry License
que es para tenerlo ahí donde tienes que
pasar un tipo de prueba tiene que
huellas digitales demostrar que sabe ser
el arma que no tiene récord criminal
etcétera son dos cosas diferentes ahora
bien el ciclo es muy pero que muy
difícil de romper de nuevo porque la la
preposición es que aunque yo aunque yo
sea un criminal que salga de la cárcel
que tenga muchísimo récord criminal que
tenga una gran experiencia creo que sea
un criminal de carrera siempre voy a
conseguir armas en el mercado negro
siempre va a haber cientos o miles de
armas ilegales que voy a poder conseguir
Entonces el ciudadano para defenderse de
ese criminal
siempre va a tratar de adquirir de armas
legales y la persona que quiere
consiga el carry dice Bueno en cualquier
momento cualquier persona puede volverse
loca puede tener algún Arrebato de
esquizofrenia yo puede tratar de hacer
algún tipo de acto terrorista también
puede tener un concier License carry
para defenderme en la calle son dos
cosas Una cosa de la defensa en la en la
casa y otra cosa es la autodefensa en la
calle entendido ese punto ron Gracias
por la aclaración paso a preguntarle
entonces a Refugio por este doble efecto
y cómo romper el círculo cómo Entonces
crear una iniciativa no sé usted Cómo la
ve si esto debe ser presión de la
sociedad estadounidense hacia el
congreso hacia el gobierno para pedir
que se reestructuren las leyes que
permiten el porte la venta la defensa
que haya una reestructuración de las
leyes o esto tiene que ser una un una
iniciativa que parta de las autoridades
Cuál va a ser el punto de quiebre o
desde el gobierno o desde la sociedad
pues la realidad es de que yo pensé
realmente después de Sandy de Sandy dijo
cuando nada ocurrió en términos de
limitaciones acceso a a calibres de alto
poder armas de alto poder y de alta
capacidad este realmente yo no pienso
que
que políticamente va a haber cambios
verdad este
uno pensaría que la muerte de niños
inocentes sería realmente un criar a un
gran cambio Después de ubalde yo pensé
también de nuevo entonces la verdad es
de que más queda este Al mismo punto ya
cuando mueren niños a causa de este
acceso a estas terribles armas que
realmente no tienen fin más que para la
guerra son que fueron creadas muchas de
Estas armas para la guerra que son
usadas ya en cualquier persona puede
tener entonces y yo diría de que de que
el público Yo pienso que ya está harto
al mismo tiempo lo que no he visto es
que pasa Acaso en caso y no hay ningún
cambio político este los cambios que yo
he visto que empiezan a cambiar son
localmente en términos de vigilancia en
términos de servicios de salud mental en
términos de de prevención este en muchos
casos y yo pienso que esas son las
inversiones que debemos hacer porque
realmente este como el trabajo que hago
yo no es en legislación porque realmente
la legislación hasta este punto no nada
más es difícil pero es casi imposible y
y la sociedad y y políticamente no nos
importa cuando mueren tantos niños
inocentes en la escuela Entonces qué va
a hacer este la situación que va a
causar algún cambio Si eso no nos hace
cambiar Entonces no sé qué
ese es un punto importante refugio y lo
que uno no entiende continuó con usted
es porque el gobierno o las autoridades
no les sorprenden ya este tipo de de
actos no le sorprenden este tipo de
tiroteos masivos y Tal parece que no
entienden que es mejor prevenir este
tipo de actos porque también para el
Estado esto implica una carga no entrar
en la parte de los juicios con la
persona que ha incurrido en este tipo de
actos indemnizar a las familias de las
víctimas lo que cuesta para renovar
Entonces
al equipo de policías que habían allí
porque los que estuvieron no dieron la
talla no funcionaron como no procedieron
como tenían que proceder hay que
sacarlos de sus cargos Es decir para el
Estado esto es una gran carga de gastos
cada vez que hay un tiroteo por todos
los procedimientos que hay que hacer a
nivel legal solamente la investigación
cuánto le vale a un estado A un condado
o al Gobierno Federal el gobierno no lo
entiende de esa manera
la verdad es que no ese Eso es parte del
trabajo que hago yo y trabajar con
condados y con ciudades para que
empiecen a analizar realmente el costo
de no hacer nada cada vez que hay un
homicidio
en la comunidad qué tanto estamos
invirtiendo en la investigación la
persecución hospitalización Y eso de
nuevo no cuenta los otros costos que
vienen con eso y Y la verdad es de que
es muy caro tener simplemente la pérdida
de vida en en en en en comunidades por
todo este país más de 45.000 personas
mueren al año a causa de de armas de
fuego en este país cada año Entonces
cuando estamos cuando empezamos a ver el
costo y analizar todo eso este Sale sale
muy muy caro este en términos de lo que
estamos perdiendo en términos de costos
al mismo tiempo diría que yo pienso que
políticamente es difícil porque la
economía este que existe este a causa de
la de armas de fuego en este país No
nomás en este país pero como estábamos
hablando de de tráfico de armas dentro
de Estados Unidos es muy grande pero el
tráfico de armas que sale de Estados
Unidos a México y a latinoamérica hoy en
día estamos viendo el problema que está
causando con lo que estamos viendo en
términos de migración a este país eso
viene de armas también y eso eso no lo
estamos viendo tampoco políticamente
pero de nuevo es una gran cifra el
dinero que se hace de la venta de armas
claro todo es un es un negocio Así es
como se ve el tema de la venta de las
armas ron regreso con usted para
preguntarle por por una una calificación
que tal vez
no sé usted cómo lo vaya a tomar pero la
perspectiva que uno puede tener fuera de
Estados Unidos es con todo esto que
ustedes explican del mercado negro de
las armas del envío de armas de Estados
Unidos hacia países como México
Centroamérica o Sudamérica para ser
usadas allí en el crimen organizado el
mercado negro al interior de estados
unidos podemos calificar a Estados
Unidos como un país inseguro porque por
lo menos así es como se ve desde afuera
y uno pensaría
en cualquier momento me puede pasar a mí
en Estados Unidos estar envuelto en un
tiroteo masivo
bueno en en No hay ninguna Por decirlo
así ninguna garantía que uno no va a ser
un turista en una gran ciudad y y no va
a haber allí un tiroteo masivo como
tampoco hay ninguna garantía que yo vaya
a París Francia y como en el 2015 que
hubo ataques terroristas y murieron más
de 100 personas por los ataques
terroristas es una cuestión impredecible
ahora bien las estadísticas que nos da
el departamento de Justicia
el FBI es que Estados Unidos es bastante
seguro siempre y cuando sepas a dónde ir
a Estados Unidos Ese es el el asunto y y
tengo que que tocarlo de una manera
controversial pero es que hay de nuevo
una cosa son los tiroteos armados
masivos en la escuela que es un fenómeno
extraordinario y un fenómeno particular
es una cosa particular ubalde Sandy Hook
etcétera esas son cuestiones
particulares
ahora bien la violencia con las armas ya
desde un punto de vista más general
hablando desde generalizando eso ocurre
más que nada en en ciertas ciudades y es
más que nada en ciertos barrios de
ciertas ciudades por ejemplo Chicago el
sur de Chicago es uno de los sitios más
calientes Por decirlo así con más alta
incidencia de crímenes de armas y los y
otros barrios de otras grandes ciudades
como Nueva York como Oakland y ahí es
donde estamos muy concentrados la
violencia callejera las entre las
pandillas entre las diferentes llangas
en irme más lejos en el 2000 en el 2021
a principios de 2021 el FBI
sacó sus estadísticas y y desde el año
2020 y murieron aproximadamente Diez mil
personas
todo de raza negra en el año 2020 Y esa
y esos se debieron más que nada al
crimen entre Pandilla de esta etnia
entre ellos y eso se va precisamente a
los sitios más calientes que ya mencioné
el sur de Chicago etcétera tú te vas a
Estados como Vermont derecho tiene
muchísimas armas y te vas a estar como
New hampshire te vas a estar como
muchísimos estados te puede decir como
Wyoming y de ahí realmente la tasa de
Crimen y de seguridad pública es Es la
misma que te encuentras en Luxemburgo
en Europa etcétera O sea que no es
cuestión de que sea Estados Unidos
inseguro es cuestión del sitio preciso
donde Estados Unidos que es inseguro y
que hay de la recurrencia de la cantidad
de y frecuencia la cantidad de tiroteos
masivos que se están presentando en
Estados Unidos cada vez son más de
acuerdo a los a los a las cifras y se
comparan con años anteriores Se está
perdiendo sensibilidad en la sociedad de
Estados Unidos frente a este tema antes
veía uno gran despliegue de los medios
de comunicación hablando sobre esto
ahora algunos medios solamente lo tocan
en algunos de los de los noticieros de
la Hora punta de mayor audiencia y para
otros simplemente pasa como una noticia
más del día Se está perdiendo
sensibilidad y también como esto no está
generando un show mediático que también
es un factor importante para la sociedad
de Estados Unidos qué tanto de esto se
puede sacar para generar audiencias
rating y sacarle provecho a nivel
mediático
bueno los rating pues obviamente aquí se
compite muchísimo Por eso ahora bien más
que competencia de rating Yo diría que
el asunto está por decirlo así dirigido
por la línea editorial de los medios de
comunicación todo depende de la línea
editorial que tenga la cuando me refiero
línea editorial me refiero línea
política o inclinación política que
tengan los medios de comunicación por
ejemplo los grandes crímenes que que
salen por miles y miles entre las
pandillas o casi todos de raza negra en
Chicago esos son prácticamente
invisibles a la prensa eso es
prácticamente no salen es claro los toma
nota toma nota el FBI toma nota la
policía de Chicago toma nota el
departamento de Justicia pero son
invisibles ahora bien cada vez que hay
un tiroteo de más de cinco seis siete
personas y y no son de raza negra las
personas pues usualmente ahí ya
usualmente medios de comunicación presta
muchísima más atención y si es un medio
de comunicación que está asociado con el
partido demócrata siempre van a tratar
de destino van a tratar de dar una un
tipo de narrativa diciendo Ah fue
personal posiblemente fue una persona de
derecha Blanca seguidor de Trump que
mató a esta gente Sí yo tratan de poner
así porque va de acuerdo con su
narrativa y va de acuerdo también con la
narrativa del partido demócrata O sea
que no es cuestión de que sea invisible
o no hay que recordar un país de 330
millones de personas siempre va a tener
crimen siempre va a tener personas
perturbadas mentalmente con
esquizofrenia que etcétera
estos que acaban de pasar en California
ahora mismo que son personas asiáticas
matando a otra persona asiáticas lo
sabrá Dios Por qué razón muy
probablemente psiquiátrica pero
usualmente es el la el medio la
orientación de la editorial que tenga el
medio de comunicación si va a exponer o
no Uno de estos crímenes y ahí también
va de acuerdo a ese despliegue la
respuesta de la sociedad si dan un
bombardeo informativo sobre el tema pues
las personas pueden mostrarse más
interesadas si simplemente pasa
desapercibido pues las personas ni
siquiera se enteran de qué fue lo que
sucedió y no le dan importancia Quiero
preguntarle a Refugio sobre este tema a
nivel mediático porque esto también
lleva a un efecto importante que es la
imitación muchas personas Al ver todas
las resonancia que tienen estos hechos
en los medios de comunicación y en esta
búsqueda de fama o de popularidad que
también tiene un poco arraigada a las
sociedades de Estados Unidos Pues dicen
Pues yo porque no lo puedo hacer si esto
me va a dar visibilidad lo estoy viendo
en los medios de comunicación como lo ve
usted
Pues sí de cierta forma puede ser así y
y los y los medios de comunicación
también contribuían a eso verdad estamos
aquí ahorita por qué porque fue una
persona fueron dos personas este que
externalizaron este sus problemas o su
trama en aspectos violentos hacia otras
personas entonces por eso este los
medios de comunicación están enfocados
hoy pero yo diría que hay un alto número
de personas que
internalizaron ese mismo dolor o esas
esos problemas que tenían y se quitaron
la vida y no hablamos nada de eso pero
colectivamente de nuevo es ese esa cifra
es mucho más alta que que las lo que
estamos viendo en en estos casos de
tiroteo Y de nuevo no estamos no estoy
disminuyendo la importancia de que
debemos hablar de tiroteos masivos Pero
por eso digo yo que para mí el problema
y y lo que conecta todo esto es el
acceso a esas armas especialmente armas
de alta calibre este y y los medios de
comunicación deben de enfocarse en ese
tipo de conversación y hacer un propio
análisis con de la información y lo que
está ocurriendo y no Simplemente este
Elevar lo que lo que va nos va a dar
ratings verdad sí eso eso me lleva a
preguntarle Refugio sobre
ese poco consenso que hay en Estados
Unidos frente a la denominación de un
tiroteo
Cuántas personas tienen que morir para
que sea considerado un tiroteo y para
que sea considerado una historia que
merece ser contada en los medios de
comunicación pero es que finalmente está
muriendo gente como lo dice Usted no
solamente por por un tiroteo masivo la
gente se quita la vida por ese fácil
acceso también que hay a la venta de las
armas Pues lo más fácil es [__] un arma
y terminar con con mi vida
esa falta de consenso en cuanto a lo que
se considera Entonces esto Sí vale la
pena contarlo
No sí
el consenso es una cosa en términos de
de los medios de comunicación verdad
tener la información apropiada las
estadísticas toda la información para
que sepan porque este en mi caso imagino
que de otras personas también cuando nos
cuando nos hablan es porque tenemos que
hablar porque algo ha ocurrido y es
cuando damos información verdad Pero esa
información debe de estar al acceso de
todos los medios de comunicación para
para que ellos más sepan realmente lo
que está ocurriendo este no nomás aquí
pero en el país y Y la verdad es de que
de que no debe de haber políticamente Yo
pienso que no hay consenso más que en
una cosa lo que estamos haciendo al
momento no funciona y sigue
incrementando entonces eso debe ser el
consenso que la que los medios de
comunicación deben tener es Qué vamos a
hacer cada vez qué vamos a hacer
diferente Qué vamos a hacer diferente
porque estar sorprendidos de que otra
escuela hubo un tiroteo en otra escuela
o que cinco personas murieron eso ya
pasamos ese tiempo hace años Sí pero
cuántos más tienen que morir para que
haya una atención especial por parte del
gobierno para empezar a tomar cartas en
el asunto me queda un minuto para
finalizar el programa Run sus
conclusiones Qué se debe hacer
rápidamente para empezar a romper este
círculo vicioso y para para darle
solución a esta problemática en Estados
Unidos
Bueno hay leyes federales que que me
parecen a mí que son de sentido común
que no son extremistas ni son que van a
encontrar que no van contra la cultura
Estados Unidos por ejemplo subir el la
edad mínima para tener un rifle de 18 a
21 años Eso me parece a mí bastante de
sentido común porque a los 18 años es
cuando más sensible y vulnerables son
los adolescentes psicológicamente y
emocionalmente O sea que eso me parece a
mí bastante de sentido común y lo que
está haciendo por ejemplo estados como
como Florida Me parece muy bien ahí
policías que se dedican única y
exclusivamente a seguir en las redes
sociales Instagram Facebook adolescente
cualquier amenaza cualquier indicio me
parece a mí que que eso puede ser Se
puede seguir siendo de muy mucho muy
beneficioso beneficioso
rápidamente segundos para su conclusión
Yo pienso que hay diferentes soluciones
Pero lo que sí hemos visto que ha
funcionado es fue la restricción a armas
de alta calibre eso
hizo una gran diferencia Y eso para mí
sería donde empezar hay hay mucho más
Este
podemos hacer sí Refugio se me acaba el
tiempo ustedes saben cómo es esto en
televisión les agradezco mucho por haber
hecho este análisis para la audiencia de
France 24 la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y
la producción de invitados a cargo de
Tania Herrera siga con nosotros
[Música]